this isn't the story i expected to tell
i knew coming here that this isn't some
magic beach where you can bring a shovel
and scoop up buckets and buckets of lego
it might have felt a bit like that 20
years ago but these days lego is a
little harder to find but yes
here on the coast of cornwall in the
southwest of england when the conditions
are right
you might find quite a bit of lego
scattered on perrinporth
beach in 1997 a container ship called
tokyo express was on its way to new york
when it got hit by a heavy storm off
land's end just west of here a load of
containers got
knocked into the sea and one of them
contained almost five
million little plastic pieces of lego
most of which were ocean themed flippers
spears octopuses
all crashing around in the waves and
currents the far end of this beach has
the right conditions there's a huge
expanse of sand the wind's in the right
direction
but the pieces can wash up anywhere
that's the nice cute story
that i was gonna tell we find the lego
after high spring tides and winter
storms and that's when the
waves will eat into the dunes and
release a lot of the plastic that's been
washed
ashore many years ago that's tracy
williams she's been beachcombing here
for years and runs a photography project
called lego lost at sea
tracy didn't want to be on camera which
is frankly sensible but
she was nice enough to show off some of
her lego collection to take me
beachcombing here on the far end of the
beach
and to chat about what she's found over
the years so i got my gopro ready we
went out for a walk on the shore
and that's where the story i thought i
was gonna tell didn't work anymore
when you've got it in a little jar with
all the bright colors
it looks it looks almost quaint and then
the reality is a bit different
no the reality is horrifying isn't it so
if you look here
so absolutely so this is actually a
plastic pebble
plastic yes how can you tell the
difference fill the weight
oh huh nobody really knows where they're
coming from but they're thought to be
the remains of beach bonfires
so i've actually picked up 20 000 of
those it's actually from an
ale cask these are from packaging strips
these are what they put around
cartons to protect them from your
packaging shotgun woods
shotgun cartridges bottle caps i mean
what
what do we do with like you've just got
to bring a trash bag and just yes i
normally come down
armed with sacks that's a glow stick
from fishing
so that's the oh yeah of a turn
so these get discarded on garage full
courts and tire places and they just get
washed into the drain and the drains go
straight to the sea a lot will be
litter dropped on streets eighty percent
of litter dropped on the streets
is said to make its way to the sea wow
it's not just lego that's the way people
like to tell it but it's not just lego
it's so
many plastic things and it's not just
this beach
once you start looking immediately
bright white bright blue bright yellow
yeah
if i was looking at this from a distance
i would have just read it all as seaweed
it's actually not as bad today
as it sometimes is but i can't see how
it's ever going to get better
in a way it's a sort of pointless
exercise constantly picking it up
i'm just kind of got a sort of creeping
horror at this point
do you get used to that get used to
seeing this amount of plastic
yeah yeah there's this cliche in horror
movies where the characters suddenly
realize that
the monster that they've heard about
this abstract thing is actually
in the room with them and has been there
the whole time and
that's kind of what this felt like
because i've been going to beaches like
this all my life and
i never noticed the bright colors that
were right in front of me
so on this beach you get a lot of the
floating plastic
so you've got all the fragments of
plastic you've got the nerdles these
little tiny
nerds those aren't stones those are no
these are these are little plastic
nerdles these are the raw material that
all plastic items are made from
there's billions of them so summer
nerdles
you also get ones that are black and
ridged
and they're actually bio beads that are
used in waste water treatment
plants and then you sort of pull back
the camera and you realize that it's
it's all of this there's so much of it
on some beaches you get
the plastic that sinks to the ocean
floor and it washes the shore with the
kelp with the brown seaweed
they've probably been swirling around
the seabed for the last 24 years
and every now and again they wash ashore
with a seaweed and this goes
down that we assume it does so a lot of
it is buried under where we are now it
needs to come out
quite a lot of the toys we find you can
date them
and some date back to the 50s and 60s
especially the cereal packet toys we
recently did some experiments in the lab
to see how long lego
would last in the marine or coastal
environment and the scientists that did
the experiments worked out that it could
last up to 1300 years
i wonder if one day you'll just be able
to recognize it by the
color yeah bright green of the seaweed
or the the yellow of the life boots
oh look treasure treasure is that one of
the dwarves from snow white
it's not every beach but it's a lot of
them tucked away in corners where the
tourists don't
go or just in plain sight there was
seaweed on another beach
filled with plastic once you see it i've
just seen a lego boom
yes just there yes what do you know
thank you among all the other plastic
waste
there still is lego washing up did they
used to be more lego is it has it
changed over the years yes i think
there's definitely less
lego than there used to be and there's
lots of people looking out for it now
you only ever see what floats really you
never really hear about all the
items from cargo spills that sink to the
bottom of the sea because the rest of it
is going to be out
on the ocean floor somewhere yeah that's
bleak
i don't have a neat ending for the story
i was going to say oh if you're on the
beach in south west england it's worth
keeping your eyes down from time to time
maybe you'll see some lego
but even if you don't maybe take a bag
with you
and take some plastic away because
there's a lot of it
the lego lost at sea project is on
instagram twitter and facebook and
there's also a link to pre-order tracy's
book
down in the description
if i look uh if it looks slightly
distracted uh during that it's because
halfway through
i realized that there is green nylon
rope
just in the seaweed just hanging out
there